in the last two videos you learn to
think about the structure of language
using logic I introduced using symbols
for constants and variables and how to
break statements into subject and
predicate it's time to look at some
logical symbols that will give our
sentences a bit more structure starting
with quantifiers when we talk about a
quantity we mean how many of something
there are but ordinary language is
fairly general even vague in its
treatment of quantity one house two or
more houses this is actually true of
logic too we'll look at three basic
quantities none sum which is one or more
and all each of these quantities is the
symbol so we will have three symbols
that we can call quantifiers first
here's the quantifier all remember when
we use predicates with variables we
ended up with sentences like X is a
person but this doesn't tell us anything
about that X let's use X as a quantifier
for any X X is a person let's try that
with the sentence X all Y we get for any
X X all Y one step further with for any
X for any Y X all Y when I use any with
these variables I'm really referring to
all the things x and y can stand for so
let's throw the universal quantifier all
into the mix we get the sentence for all
X X is a person in ordinary language you
can read that as all of them are people
or just all people or all humans let's
look at another one for all X Jill saw X
here we're basically saying Jill saw
everything but if we abandon these
quantifiers and just let the predicate
we'd end up with blank is a person and
Jill saw Blake okay let's move to
another symbol this one is the
existential quantifier it acts like the
universal quantifier all you just
learned about but instead it means sum
or more specifically there exists at
least one
let's go back to our variable X in the
phrase X is a person let's say we wanted
to talk about some person in other words
for some X where X is a person we'll
need to use an existential quantifier
we'll also you need to use it for the
sentence that Jill saw something
remember that Jill saw everything used
the universal quantifier all but for
Jill saw something we'll use the
quantifier some our final quantifier is
the symbol no take a statement P this P
might represent John saw the movie or my
house is red then the negation of that
statement not P would have the same form
as John didn't see the movie or my house
isn't red I'm listing two ways of
writing the not symbol but both have the
same meaning take another statement this
time with an individual constant and a
predicate as you saw in the last lesson
you can write john saw the movie this
way now let's turn the state same
statement into a negative John didn't
see the movie
see how that works same goes for my
house isn't red that's how a predicate
is negated same applies to the two
predicates with variables X isn't a
person X didn't see Y but don't forget
that you learn to quantify your
variables with all in some take examples
with a variable like some person which I
wrote as there exists at least one X
where X is a person and all people or
for all X X is a person we can actually
negate both of these think about it for
a moment if we negate this sum X what
does it mean not for some X X as a
person that's no people or no person if
we negate this universal quantifier over
here what does that mean not all X where
X is a person consider the difference if
there is not some X then there is no X
if there is not all X we're still left
with some X take another example to be
clear on this something is a turtle
versus everything is a turtle if I
negate the first one I get nothing is
eternal
if I negate the second one I get not
everything as a turtle before you take
quantifiers and run with them consider
how we've been using variables with
quantifiers instead of translating all
languages this way we'll say for all X X
is a language same way with the
existential quantifier the logic for
some fish is given some X X is a fish
this is how you'll use predicates and
variables to lay out logical sentences
let's look at how to render more general
terms in logic when we have words like
someone somewhere something and like the
existential quantifier comes into play
someone is for some X X is human
something is for some X or if you're
trying to bring out its thingness given
some X X as a thing with that in mind
what's everybody and everything in logic
take a moment to think about it okay if
your answer is use the universal
quantifier congratulations if not don't
despair there are many more examples to
come this gives you some perspective on
the scope of a quantifier variables of a
predicate are bound by a quantifier to
their left the nearest applicable
quantifier to be precise x is bound by a
quantifier on X Y by a quantifier on Y
in the proposition for all X X sees Y X
is bound by the universal quantifier but
Y is free on the other hand both x and y
are bound in for all X there exists some
Y where X sees Y notice that the
predicate X sees why falls within the
scope of these quantifiers the variables
x and y are also bound in the following
cases for X X is read and given Y X sees
Y in that second example Y is bound but
X is free why would you want to bind
variables this is crucial to your logic
picture it this way the variable is like
a blank space John saw Blake if you bind
the variable you can form a sentence in
a language on saw something otherwise
you're leaving the blank space there
binding requires more work
but it's crucial to logical thinking and
modeling real sentences and logic now
let's get to some translations before we
bring this lesson to a close
do your best to come up with the
following in logic and there you have it
next time we'll take a look at logical
operators which will add some flesh to
the bones of your logic skills